et samedi sera festif une grande fête
est organisée
mélanie vous nous emmenez à maurepas à
la fête du village organisée par
l'association ne ment pas d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui alors cette association
organise de nombreuses fêtes sur la
commune notamment la veillée villageoise
qui a lieu en novembre ou en décembre
elle travaille aussi sur l'histoire et
la conservation du patrimoine ancien et
de la ville nouvelle
alors c'est une fête elle qui est
organisé depuis la création de
l'association 1970 et depuis 17 ans elle
se déroule sur la place de la grand mare
alors c'est bien sûr rendez vous à vivre
en famille et de nombreuses animations
pour les enfants action sculptera des
ballons il y aura de la pêche à la ligne
il y aura du chamboule tout et même un
stand de maquillage mais pas cash qui
nous avons aussi un bal gratuit en fait
pour tout les personnes présentes dont
ils peuvent danser sur la place donc
c'est surtout une fête familiale et
conviviale en fait tout au tout les
familles aiment se rassembler et avancer
une date qui notait régulièrement sur
les calendriers des bords croisés et les
festivités commencent dès 18h 18h30
c'est bien ça et ça se termine à minuit
alors vous pourrez aussi assister à une
démonstration de twirling bâton c'est
une discipline sportive et artistique
est originaire à des états unis il y
aura un bal qui sera animé par le groupe
dans son bolide et durant cette soirée
lire aussi un repas proposé par
l'auberge le village alors un dîner
champêtre où vous pourrez notamment
déguster des grillades et des frites
une autre fête à ne pas manquer celle du
quartier de la clé saint-pierre à
elancourt celle ci débute à 14h30 et au
programme du maquillage un manège une
loterie et de la barbe à papa donc un
samedi très festif en prévision alors
que ce soit à maurepas où il encourt en
tout cas merci mélanie nous avoir parlé
de ces rendez vous